[Music]
[Applause]
this program brought to you by
draftkings download the draftkings
sportsbook app now and use the promo
code patrick get 200 and free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game that's code
patrick owning a draftking sports book
an official sports betting partner of
the nfl he's ross tucker cbs westwood
one color analyst he'll be on the call
for the titans and the bills on westwood
one coming up tonight ross good to have
you on the program again let me start
with this if i told you a month ago
these quarterbacks would lead their
teams to a win in week two jimmy
garoppolo joe flacco jared goff daniel
jones or cooper rush
what would be more surprising with that
statement
oh geez
um
man probably cooper rush because i i
wouldn't have thought that dak would get
hurt that early and cooper rush would be
out there but
i think any of those guys are surprising
right i mean that's
one of things i think is so interesting
about the nfl dan
and on some level i guess it makes it
better but it also makes it worse you
know the injury risk
the fact that teams fates can change in
an instant like what might have happened
with the 49ers yesterday the fact that
every game is a unique entity because
you don't know who's playing it changes
the game plan even that saints bucks
game to already play that game in week
two with no julio jones no chris godwin
no alvin kamara i i don't know that i
would go so far as say it's one of
things that makes football better or
makes the nfl better but it certainly
makes it more interesting than the other
sports that something that happens a lot
i would agree with you with cooper rush
because that would have meant that dak
prescott got injured i wouldn't have
been surprised with garoppolo just the
fact that i'm not quite sure how long
the leash was with trey lance i know
that they're all in and all jimmy ju
does his uh win uh flacco with zach
wilson being injured uh jared goff i'm
not surprised daniel jones i'm not
surprised now here is the conundrum and
you went to princeton so you'll
understand that
daniel jones and saquon barkley let's
say
i would say worst case scenario but best
case scenario giants go
nine and eight
now what do you do with saquon barkley's
contract what do you do with daniel
jones contract
well
obviously and i know you know this dan
it depends on how well those guys let's
say they play well
let's say they play well if you're
getting to nine wins i'm assuming saquon
barkley and daniel jones will play well
yeah i would think that the giants would
probably then
go into year five of daniel jones
because i don't know how they'd be able
to get somebody better right
um they'd have to do some type of new
contract i see i i i would be surprised
if daniel jones played well enough that
there'd be a big
market for his services
so then really for both those guys it
probably comes down to just how much
money
other teams are willing to offer them
versus what the giants are willing to
pay them i mean that would be
that would really be something because
we get to this position forget running
backs forget sake one for a second but
with quarterbacks where it's like
it just feel that there's no middle
ground it feels like nobody makes
between like 10 and 40 million dollars
you're either
over 40 and you're a starter
that the team thinks is the guy or
you're less than 10 and you're a backup
which by the way a side note hilarious
that the niners basically got jimmy to
take an 18 million dollar pay cut
because he wasn't the starter anymore
and now he is again so now the niners
just got jimmy for 18 million dollars
less i would think if that under that
scenario dan i would think that the
giants would try to bring both of them
back but i don't think they would break
the bank for either
the jimmy garop i guess it's a good
problem to have
you know i i said this a couple of weeks
ago that i was told there the veterans
in that locker room know jimmy g helps
them now
trey lance may be the future in the
future might not be now it's certainly
not now after the injury but jimmy g
they know
makes them better now
he's not as exciting but he makes them
better we saw him yesterday and
he ended up you know obviously winning
the game but is there a scenario where
what if they go to the super bowl
and jimmy g is the quarterback
like jay you have to bring him back
well that's what's really going to be
interesting because
under that scenario i think you have to
consider it strongly
and then there's the whole trade land
situation then the last time he really
played
was the fall of 2019
at the fcs level remember
2020 there was no fcs football in the
fall
2021 he played that one game then he got
drafted didn't play last year obviously
other than a game or two played one game
this year i mean next year trey lance
will be going into the year
number one coming off a major injury
number two
basically three years without playing
that's not good there's nobody out there
nobody in the world that would say you
know what's really good for young
quarterback three years of not playing
at all hardly and just watching it it
puts the niners in a really tough spot
with lance moving forward especially if
jimmy plays well and they go on another
extended playoff run i think they're
gonna have to consider their options at
that point how excited would you be if
you're a dolphin fan
unbelievably excited
i mean can you imagine all the years
they've had recently
where they haven't been good where they
haven't really been talked about
to come from behind in the fashion that
they did against a good team like
baltimore although baltimore i have no
idea what they were doing with some of
their coverages
uncharacteristic mental error just
letting tyree kill wide open 10 yards
behind everybody but still they did it
those are the type of games the dolphins
haven't won
for years and you got to be so fired up
because number one it feels like you
have the right coach the players like
him you're 2-0 and he's getting the most
out of two uh you've got this dynamic
wide receiver duo i'm just trust their
tua
no
oh
yeah see like
that bothers me
because i pride myself in dad jokes
and like i want to use that now the rest
of the week you can but do i have to say
like if i don't know what radio hit i do
the rest of the week do i have to say
well actually dan patrick said that on
his show that's not really mine i'm
stealing that no you're on our team
it's okay good yeah whatever you want
just take it and i'm taking it that is
amazing
how about this okay
i'm doing the bills titans tonight okay
somehow the dolphins might come up okay
i am going to try
to get a 2 uh and 0 reference in the
broadcast tonight and if i do
i'll let fritzy and paulie know you guys
can cut the audio that's now my goal is
to somehow mention listen the bills need
to win tonight tom i'm doing tom
mccarthy because you know the dolphins
are too uh
by the way it'll be the niners and the
broncos
week three on sunday night football boy
the fans didn't take long for them to
turn on the new head coach and the new
quarterback there uh booing them in a
less than inspiring win over the texans
what exactly needs to change with the
broncos here
it's so bad dan honestly i was thinking
about this this morning
i'm not sure i can remember
a head coach
getting off to a worse start
to his tenure than nathaniel hackett and
they actually won a game they're one and
one
but just in terms i mean dan
the the short yardage and goal line play
calling is crazy but the delay of games
the lack of knowing what they want to do
the burning of timeouts the whole crowd
doing a 10 second countdown you know i
heard fritzy last week okay and fritzy
was freaking out and you guys were like
fritzy it's one game and i agree with
all you guys like fritzy chill out dudes
one game not anymore i mean
in all sincerity
what are the odds
what are the chances that nathaniel
hackett ends up being a really good
coach after this it just it seems really
small it's certainly possible but it
seems small that you can be this
unorganized this inept
and then end up being like a top five
top ten head coach i mean he might end
up being okay they might hate they might
win 10 games this year i don't know
but
it couldn't have possibly gotten off to
a worse start if i was a denver fan like
fritzy i would be horrified right now
ross tucker cbs westwood one color
analyst host of the ross tucker football
podcast joining us on behalf of
draftkings he's on the call for the
titans at the bills westwood one coming
up tonight how concerned would you be
about your indianapolis colts
oh very i mean but
how does this happen you got a good
offensive line you got maybe the best
running back in the game and you got
matt ryan there you got a pretty good or
opportunistic defense
and you get
you get roughed up by the jags
i'll tell you how it happens
because the way the nfl works is
for whatever reason
whatever weakness you have
it seems like it almost always gets
exacerbated and michael pittman
not being able to play that game
reinforced that the colts are not good
enough at wide receiver
their worst position group is receiver
they had one guy they could count on
pitman he didn't play
there's no separation
ryan has nowhere to go with the ball the
o-line actually is not as good as
they're supposed to be because the left
tackle's not good the right guards are
concerned
it's a mess and you think about all
off-season dan it was jim irsay
basically every chance he got
ripping carson wentz subtly and saying
how different things were how much
better things were i mean he's gonna try
to trade carson wentz again that's how
bad that loss was to the jags i guess
they're 0-1-1
but it feels like they're a lot worse
the bengals situation is puzzling
because they went out
and and well they they acquired new
talent on the offensive line i don't
know if they improved the offensive line
because joe burrow's been sacked 13
times now they could have won both of
those games
but
is this
a bigger issue
or is it just
ease up here it's only week two with the
bengals no i think there's some
legitimate concerns now i do think
over time the offensive line will get
better i mean they've got
four new pieces basically in place at
left guard center right guard right
tackle that position group and i can
speak to it
continuity chemistry
that does make a difference although
they should be better than they have
been there's one thing i will say though
dan that i don't see anybody else ever
say
joe burrow needs to get rid of the ball
yeah yeah i mean i love joe burrow but
he takes too many sacks he takes sacks
he absolutely cannot and should not take
he did this last year he's doing it
again
a lot of times quarterback sacks are
more a quarterback stat than people give
him credit for everybody oh o-line sucks
o-line sucks joe burrows needs to get
rid of the ball too dan
it's always good to talk to you have fun
tonight and uh we'll we'll be listening
uh we appreciate you know maybe the
shout out there
we'll see whether or not the bills can
get to to uh an o as well
doesn't work when you say the other team
no it doesn't work no it doesn't thank
you ross see you there that's ross
tucker joining us on behalf of
draftkings download the draftkings
sportsbook app now use the promo code
patrick get 200 in free bets instantly
when you place a five dollar bet on any
football game so the promo code is
patrick only a draftking sportsbook and
for official sports betting partner of
the nfl